con determinación se alistan en el
ejército y juran lealtad este año el
momento es especialmente solemne para
los jóvenes soldados y sus padres aquí
en el cuartel Julius lever de Berlín
pero la mente de todos está más al este
en la Guerra de Ucrania la invasión rusa
de Ucrania ha vuelto la guerra a Europa
poner un pie en estos cuarteles no es un
paso pequeño lo han visto bien estas
últimas semanas
los tiempos cambian y la ambición de
Alemania también su objetivo convertirse
en el mayor ejército de Europa en la
otan el parlamento ha creado un fondo
especial de 100 mil millones de euros
para poner en forma al ejército o bundes
para los jóvenes reclutados que se
incorporarán a un batallón de guardia
hacer su carrera en las fuerzas armadas
ha adquirido un nuevo significado Johan
Klein tiene 17 años y dice haber
encontrado su habitación
para la disciplina
para ayudar a los necesitados y para
mantener la paz
estoy orgullosa de él Aunque al
principio cuando se alistó estaba un
poco asustada
Pero algún desverle espera un reto
gigantesco su equipamiento es a menudo
obsoleto la burocracia pesada los
soldados desmotivados un informe
parlamentario calificó su situación de
alarmante y muchos expertos dicen que ni
siquiera podría proteger al país y un
ata enemigos
[Aplausos]
para jeans la Guerra de Ucrania ha
supuesto un cambio repentino
vamos a conseguir el dinero que
necesitamos nuevos vehículos munición y
todo lo que sigue vamos a conseguir
equipos más modernos muchas cosas van a
cambiar estamos en un proceso necesario
de renovación
el ejército alemán tiene oficialmente
180 mil soldados pero hay miles de
puestos sin cubrir por eso está en
marcha una campaña de reclutamiento una
serie en Youtube sobre la vida en el
batallón de guardias es muy popular
entre los jóvenes
pero la bundes ver no solo está en las
redes sociales también Busca reclutas en
las ferias de empleo sigue siendo el
empleador favorito de los estudiantes de
secundaria justo después de la policía
hay una parte militar para los que
quieren ser soldados pero también
trabajan en la parte civil el ejército
ofrece más de 100 tipos de cursos de
formación profesional
en informática en ciencias sociales
pero también en trabajos de campo como
la medicina
nadie quiere que ocurra lo peor Pero si
ocurre podría ayudarle a la gente
cuidarla y estaría dispuesto a hacerlo
por Alemania
en las semanas que siguieron a la
invasión de Ucrania el tráfico en el
sitio web de la bundes ver se ha
duplicado dos tercios de la población se
declaran ahora a favor de su
modernización
no es de extrañar que 22 años después de
la reunificación de Alemania y del fin
de la guerra fría la reservas del
ejército fueron las invitadas de honor
durante la celebraciones del día de la
unidad alemana en airfurt las reservas
son ahora algo emocionante
Quiero unirme a las reservas En caso de
que todo salga mal para ayudar y no
quedarme sentado en el sofá el ejército
alemán cuenta ahora con 31.500
ciudadanos que son convocados
ocasionalmente para reforzar a los
miembros activos de las fuerzas armadas
la ministra de defensa alemana Cristina
se ha pasado por allí para hacer una
inspección rápida y dice que tendrán una
nueva importancia
estamos entrando en una era en la que es
importante proteger las infraestructuras
críticas pero también desarrollar una
cierta capacidad de recuperación en la
sociedad en ese sentido los reservistas
cumplen una misión muy importante
en un país que puso fin al servicio
militar obligatorio en 2011 estos
hombres y mujeres llamados a cumplir
todo tipo de misiones importantes en
territorio Alemán La bundesberg no da
cifras pero dice que ha habido un
aumento de solicitudes
nadie podía imaginar que en estos
tiempos alguien cambiaría las fronteras
del país de forma tan violenta como lo
ha hecho Putin es obvio que esto ha
cambiado la situación así que de repente
el interés de la gente por nuestra
capacidad de defender el país se ha
vuelto mucho más significativo
pero en un país que ha alimentado una
ideología pacifista desde el final de la
Segunda Guerra Mundial durará este
interés por el ejército al menos por
ahora todo indica que la Mentalidad está
realmente cambiando dice este experto en
política de defensa
podríamos haber tenido que la crisis
energética por ejemplo hiciera que los
alemanes no apoyaran a Ucrania Pero no
es así es una señal de que muchos
alemanes han entendido lo que está
pasando y que toda la situación de
seguridad en Europa está cambiando se
trata de un intercambio de época que tal
vez solo apenas está iniciando podría
tomar 8 años para poner al apuntes ver
en forma de combate con equipos modernos
y soldados motivados